- Avec la bataille du Donbass,
les Américains passent
à l'artillerie lourde
pour aider les Ukrainiens.
(tirs)
Ils envoient des systèmes
antiaériens, des missiles
antinavires...
des drones kamikazes
Switchblade...
et on ne lésine pas
sur les coûts; l'enveloppe
est de 3,4 milliards de dollars.
Ici, dans cet entrepôt
à Virginia Beach, on n'envoie
pas des armes, mais du matériel
de protection. On y assemble
des gilets pare-balles
tous les jours...
pour les Ukrainiens
qui se battent au front.
"Aujourd'hui, on fait
1200 gilets, dit-i
c'est 2400 plaques, en tout."
"Ce sont des plaques niveau 4,
dit-il, ce qui est le plus
haut calibre contre des balles
pour des soldats qui sont
sur la ligne de front."
Des casques et du matériel
médical sont aussi env...
Tout est emballé et acheminé
en Pologne dans ce Boeing 777.
Tous les sièges sont remplis;
24 heures plus tard,
le matériel arrive en Ukraine.
Une opération qui a lieu
tous les jours, nous dit-on,
les besoins en Ukraine
sont criants.
"Chaque jour compte",
dit Jim Hake, le fondateur
de Spirit of America,unununune t
non lucratif en collaboration
avec le gouvernement américain.
"Notre objectif est de garder
les Ukrainiens vivants", dit-il.
Une question de principe
pour Jim Hake.
"Ne soyons pas juste
des observateurs impuissants,
dit-il, mais agissons pour
faire cesser cette souffrance."
Une souffrance qui n'est pas
près de cesser, selon Joe Biden,
qui prévoit une longue guerre.
"Je veux applaudir
votre travail exceptionnel,
dit-il aux hauts gradés
militaires américains,
d'armer et d'équiper
les braves Ukrainiens
qui défendent leur pays."
Une guerre par procuration
des États-Unis contre la Russie,
diront certains, et toujours pas
question d'envoyer des soldats
américains en sol ukrainien.
Et la voie diplomatique
pour une résolution du conflit
est de moins en moins évoquée.
CHRYSTIA FREELAND,
vice-première ministre du Canada
- C'est pour les Ukrainiens,
d'être les leaders de
la diplomatie avec la Russie.
C'est la souveraineté de
l'Ukraé é é é é é é violée.
Mais on a une étroite
collaboration avec l'Ukraine.
On est là pour l'Ukraine.
- Le Canada réitère son soutien
militaire et économique
à l'Ukraine. En attendant,
la guerre continue.
Spirit of America,
elle, espère faire sa part.
Une guerre qui perdure,
où un cessez-le-feu semble,
pour le moment, illusoire.
Ici Azeb Wolde Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Virginia Beac